♫ Ah, yeah
♫ You know it's Friday night
and you're feeling right
♫ Yeah, and you going
out with your friends
♫ Catching it on Snapchat and Instagram
♫ TGIF, baby, yeah
♫ We're about to take
you all out but remember
♫ Yeah, yeah, yeah
♫ Yo
♫ Don't tag us
♫ I'm a baller, and I'm only 17
♫ Ladies holla, cos
I'm the homecoming king
♫ When I step up in the
spot I be taking them shots
♫ With the girls that are hot
with the vodka that I bought
♫ I know the kid but now we
just, yeah, and we chilling out
♫ My parents don't know I'm here
♫ They think that I'm at Dylan's house
♫ But we both here sipping
beer and the liquor
♫ It's all good here,
aw, Dylan took a picture!
♫ I'm like ♫
- Dylan, what are you doing?
- What's up?
- I'm drunk, Dylan!
You can't post those
things when I'm drunk.
My dad's gonna see me and
kick me out of the Scouts.
♫ Don't tag me
♫ OMG, finally the weekend
♫ Leaving the office, feeling (mumbles)
♫ Yeah, party till 6, and from 9 to 6
♫ Chilling with my clique
and (mumbles) chicks
♫ Turn up like Leo and
the Wolf of Wall Street
♫ Even though I'm barely making ends meet
♫ I'm popping bottles making models
♫ Blowing through paychecks
♫ I'm in debt, what the
heck, I got zero reflect ♫
- Whoa, I don't want to
see you tag me, Shane.
We're supposed to be at the
quarterly office retreat.
- Oh, I think it's already
in the cloud! I'm sorry!
- No, we're screwed!
- Uh...
♫ Don't tag me
♫ I'm a grade-A graduate,
receiving these awards
♫ It's golden and I'm out,
smartest girl on the floor
♫ Summa cum laude, business trips to Saudi
♫ Making all this paper
and investing it proudly
♫ I'm proud of being
stable, independent and more
♫ But tonight when I go out I
want to bust it on the floor
♫ In case I meet a guy who
needs to think I'm super fun
♫ Don't tag me in this pic where I make
♫ More money than him ♫
- Why not?
- Guys, we're having
fun here and everything,
but I don't want a
picture online where I'm
making more money than a dude,
it's gonna turn guys off.
It's like the whole women's rights thing
in America right now.
We're fighting for it but
we haven't gotten it yet.
It's thing long story, just don't tag me.
♫ Hell yeah it happened,
and yeah I was there
♫ But nobody has to know
if the tag isn't there
♫ Hell yeah it happened,
and yeah I was there
♫ But nobody has to know
if the tag isn't there
♫ Don't tag me when I'm drinking underage
♫ Don't tag me when I'm
kissing Kiss Fantasia
breaking up the waves
♫ Gap, don't tag me like that
♫ Don't tag me
♫ Don't tag me ♫